KANG THE CONQUEROR
You're an interesting man, Scott Lang.
You're an Avenger...
...you have a daughter...
...but you've lost a lot of time, like me.
SCOTT LANG
Who are you?
KANG THE CONQUEROR
I'm the man who can give you
more time.
JANET VAN DYNE
Scott, you cannot trust him!
YOUNG CASSIE LANG
Daddy!
SCOTT LANG
I just lost so much.
He can give us a second chance.
KANG THE CONQUEROR
You will bring me what I need...
...or everything you call a life...
...will end.
You may not want her
to watch this.
SCOTT LANG
We had a deal.
KANG THE CONQUEROR
You thought you could win?
SCOTT LANG
I don't have to win...
...we both just have to lose.
CASSIE LANG
Dad!
SCOTT LANG
I'm sorry Cassie!
[Screaming]